so I got pulled into economics in 2007
because of the 2008 economic crisis Mike
Brown who had been the first CFO of
Microsoft chief financial officer of
Microsoft and treasurer of Microsoft and
he came to Toronto in 2007 and took my
wife and I out to dinner and said he's
trying to put together a research group
to work on economics and he would like
me to be involved I said I don't know
anything about economics he said that's
ok because nobody does and the whole
system is about to collapse
he said the balance sheets of all the
big investment banks it's like they have
cancer they're full of holes I remember
being very struck by this because this
is before anybody was talking about this
and so I start to meet with a group of
people that he was pulling together to
understand what was going to happen and
to understand if there was any way to
save the situation it was a very
ambitious thing and of course we failed
but along the way I was motivated as a
kind of public service to get interested
in economics and what I found economics
in a way is very easy for physicists to
understand because it's very
mathematical and the mathematical models
if they use are very clean they're based
on assumptions hypotheses and you can
study them and then as I studied it I
began to understand some for myself and
more from just reading around because
the false with the standard economic
models with the standard models of
finance are well-known there have been
in the literature for decades and
decades so let me give some examples the
standard model of economics is called
the neoclassical model and it assumes
that markets are systems which trading
happens between consumers and firms and
there are certain simple models of how
that goes on and the ideas that these
come to equilibrium equilibrium not in
the physical sense but in special
economic sense in which you reach a
point at which the prices are fixed such
that market forces fix the prices such
that you maximize the happiness of the
consumers and maximize the profits of
the firm's
and in so-called equilibrium nobody can
become happier or more profitable
without somebody else becoming less
happy or less profitable and the
ideology behind this not behind the
mathematics because mathematics doesn't
have an ideology but behind the
arguments that were made and still are
made from this model is that markets
don't need regulation because they have
these natural equilibria where everybody
benefits to the maximum possible and if
you're in equilibrium you can't do
better now there's a fault with this and
it's an obvious fall it's been known
since the 1970s from some theorems
proved by some economists including some
of the founders of this field of
mathematical economics which is that
there's not one equilibrium there are
many equilibria fact is a vast number of
equilibria and so which equilibria even
assuming that this is a decent model of
the account of the economy which is not
clear but even assuming it's a good
model which equilibria you're in depends
on the past history depends on
regulation depends on politics depends
on taste depends on changing taste
changing preferences and so history
matters and what's called path
dependence matters this takes us outside
of the neoclassical model of economics
but it doesn't take us outside of
economics because some wiser economists
for example Brian Arthur had for years
been developing models and theories of
path-dependent economy where the history
does the patent matter people from the
area of complex systems likes to
Kaufmann provocative and developing
models of markets where the history
matters where there is not a single
equilibrium where there many equilibria
and we're change is paramount another
symptom of this is is the idea that
arbitrage isn't I mean in these
neoclassical models when you go to
equilibrium arbitrage is impossible
arbitrage is making
from training around the circle of goods
or a circle of currencies without
actually producing anything and in
equilibrium that's supposed to be
impossible but lots of firms and
investment banks and made fortunes off
of currency trading so why is that turns
out because you're never really in
equilibrium so why is the notion of
equilibrium so powerful I think part of
the answer is this idea of physics Envy
that economists thought that what
they're doing was more scientific hence
more corrective it looked like physics
and physics had this timeless picture in
which what really mattered is we were
saying before is the whole history of
the system and in physics there's also a
big notion of coming to equilibrium
which is though however it's important
to say as a different notion of
equilibrium and somehow people and
economics got seduced into this model
which again works in the small if you
have a small little corner of the
economy a small market it may work for a
while to characterize approximately
what's going on arbitrage is not always
there it's not always I mean
arbitrage opportunities do get eaten up
there are market forces which do push it
towards equilibria there's some truth in
it but the whole thing is a disaster if
I can say that as an outsider and it led
indirectly it wasn't the only reason why
regulations were lifted on markets and
trading through the decades but when
people were making arguments to Congress
to the president's office that would be
more that the economy would be better
off without regulation this was the
quote scientific rationale for it and
led to the very unstable situation of
the last economic crisis and indeed
still a very dangerous and unstable
situation in the world economy because
well I'm not an economist I'm not going
to pontificate about the problems in the
economy but one could see how the idea
of timelessness
gave false comfort to an unsuccessful
scientific theory in the realm of
economy of economics